good afternoon everybody nice to see you
this is a very big theater so some of
you are very far away but we have to try
and come down if you feel lucky just
come closer because we want this to be a
a nice intimate conversation the idea is
that this in this panel discussion which
for which we have more time we have 45
minutes there will be conversation among
the panelists but there will also be
some conversation with the audience we
do have microphones which we can use so
that you the audience members can ask
questions or make comments and so I very
much hope to involve you at various
points during the conversation thank you
how nice of you to come down thank you
that's lovely so yes if you come yeah I
will repeat it it's lovely
it's feeling very full now that's great
come down please
um Helga Novotny those of you who are
with us this morning I think that's
probably everybody we already know as a
professor from a Taha in Zurich and also
former head of the European Research
Council
Michael Leavitt is 2013 Nobel laureate
in chemistry and Frank Vil Tech is 2004
Nobel laureate in physics in fact he was
awarded the prize at the same time as
David gross who you met this morning
please and thank you and we're here to
discuss evidence and the value of
uncertainty so we are continuing in a
way that conversations about scientific
please come in come and sit down come
down the front if you feel so inclined
the we continue the discussions about
scientific truth we had this morning and
as we were hearing and learning
scientific truth is not an absolute
absolute thing it's something that is
subject to change and we must understand
that and as scientists you three are all
very used to that concept so let's start
there and talk about how you deal in
your own work with the uncertainty of
the problems and the solutions that you
why did we start with you Frank well one
way that like it or not we get to
practice dealing with uncertainty as
patients this year's Nobel Prize in
Physics for instance discovery of
gravitational waves was based on the
theory of Albert Einstein a prediction
of the general a consequence of his
general theory of relativity that's a
hundred years old and could not be
tested until an enormous program of
technical developments many of which
could not have been foreseen that
finally brought it to fruition and it
was a similar story with the Higgs boson
that took only 50 years and it's a
similar story with the microwave
background radiation which is kind of
our our prime messenger from the Big
Bang and so I'm hoping it'll be a
similar story good for except some of
the things I've been pushing so that
that's certainly one way so you're used
to decades of uncertainty before this
decades of Unser and but of course this
is not something that's a passive
process we try to help the exhibit by
suggesting new techniques for the
experimenters and encouraging further
refinements and thought to accelerate
the process and in a way so it can be
very difficult yeah but in a way it's a
necessary part because if you if you
don't have the uncertainty you're not
pushing hard enough that's right I like
to tell students when they begin with me
that if you don't make mistakes you're
not working on hard enough problems
mistakes are not only to be expected but
they're really to be welcomed because
that they're very good learning
experiences that's the perspective of a
theoretical physicist Michael you're a
biophysicist so I think uncertainty is
intrinsic and everything any measurement
has certain uncertainty I think life
itself has uncertainty I think
in any one minute you know maybe nothing
happened to you but that many many bad
things could have happened to useful in
some ways you know you're generally
ahead if you're alive
I think uncertainty can also be a very
good thing I think some of the error
that I think is particularly interesting
that scientists understand is the value
of randomness and some of the what why
randomness is so valuable is that it's
unbiased and often it's very cheap
because do anything it's that it's throw
a dice and some of those powerful
methods and optimizations for example
said the Monte Carlo method it's just
based on doing things with a certain
level of randomness and I think the lack
of bias is is a really powerful thing
about the certainty I tell people who
often come to me and say you know I have
these two choices and I can't decide and
they said but you can't decide it
doesn't really make any difference you
know decide that if the dice is over
three we'll choose option one and if the
dice is under three drop them two and do
it that way now very often when they do
it that way they suddenly the sky that
they actually prefer the other option
so sometimes redness is very very
powerful uncertainty is actually a
positive thing I think people who are
very certain about their lives miss out
on all the good stuff which is the
answer yeah I can only echo what has
been said so far but I want to do it in
my own words and I would start out by
saying we have to realize that research
is inherently uncertain don't kid
yourself if you know already what you
will find its development or you use
knowledge that is already available to
achieve a certain goal but it's not
research and this is the basic tenet of
any kind of fundamental research or blue
sky research however you call it it's
inherently uncertain because you don't
know what you're going to find you don't
know if when but and this is where
uncertainty comes in it drives you
forward you want to cover the ground of
what is still unknown you want to move
forward into the territory of the
unknown
and therefore uncertainty for scientists
is an enormous very important driving
force to do it and then I fully agree I
wrote a book the cunning of uncertainty
and one way of how we can embrace
uncertainty also outside of science but
scientists do it all the time is what
you call randomness I would call it
serendipity serendipity in research
where you find something that you have
not been looking for but and this is an
important but you are clever enough you
are lucky enough to understand the
significance and this plays an important
role in research and somehow you can
also be ready for welcoming serendipity
so if you have too many plans and if you
clutter every you know experimental
space then there is nothing left for a
third DVD to enter hmm well I think an
important part of being of theoretical
physics and I think of science generally
is to find uncertainty even in things
that most people think are certain to
look at a theory and say this could be
better look at a design and say that's
not perfect and it's really an aesthetic
process of systematically introducing
uncertainty as a way to create new
things okay so as scientists you will
accept uncertainty and in fact as you
alluded to in a way in our daily lives
we also live with uncertainty all the
time it's not such a strange concept
none very few of us I mean you said if
you live a certain life it's perhaps
more boring life but very few of us do
most of us are constantly aware that we
don't really know what decisions we
ought to make a basis
and yet the dichotomy is that although
we know that and we and maybe people
what we will to discuss whether people
do or do not understand this arts
proceeds like this people want certainty
in decision-making they want certainty
from politicians they see uncertainty as
a weakness and it's very strange why
should there be this separation between
the lives we perhaps need individually
in the law and the public life yeah it
was very important to realize that some
things are more certain than others we
had a lecture from David gross this
morning about the scientific method and
that produces kind of the gold standard
of truth when you can do repeated
experiments check things establish
things with great precision over
hundreds of years of data collection and
so even those basics can be questioned
like Newton's theory of gravity was
eventually surpassed by Einstein's
theory but there are some things that
are really really solid and well tested
but most things aren't like that
once you step out of the hard core of
physics and chemistry and into the
realms of history or the where there are
contingent events you really can't
repeat the experiments there are facts
that are just facts they're not truth
with a capital T so there are degrees of
uncertainty and the complex Sciences are
somewhere in between where you have you
know the basic principles of physics but
you don't without a lot more input know
what the weather's going to be tomorrow
there are a lot of contingent facts that
have to be added and biology is all
about contingent facts I think one of
the reasons for this I call it the
craving for certainty that we observe in
society it comes from the fact that we
live in the present but we want to know
the future we want to be able to prepare
for the future we are curious about the
future and this in itself is
a very big human invention because until
the 18th century
most people on the planet believed the
future was pretty style so some you know
gods whoever was already charting out
the course of the future and it was only
during the time of the Enlightenment and
what preceded it and through science
that it became possible to imagine that
you can at least partly shape the future
but this wishing to know the future goes
back this is why in every civilization
you had divination practices people
using big animal bones being you know
whatever to try to predict the futures
and there were specialists for doing
this the Maggie and the various people
who had the technical knowledge but they
also were advising the policy makers
they were advising the the kings or the
Chiefs of the tribes whoever this will
be your future it's it's a nice picture
that three hundred years ago this
conference had we had it would have had
three major I sitting there well you are
the major so I I think this is why we
want to know because we want to prepare
for what the future will bring and now
we don't use divination methods anymore
but we have you know the futurists there
are think tanks there are reports that
are being commissioned energy the world
in 2030 2040 2050 what will it be like
and very often these Amir extrapolations
of trends that we see now because we are
so ill-equipped for what we cannot
predict we are ill-equipped to deal with
uncertainty that comes and will surprise
us so well I think what general Hayden
said this morning was very profound what
you can use rational means to identify
is kind of a range of possibility
we can't predict in detail what's going
to happen but you can sit you it's it's
easier to say what can't happen then
what can happen and sort of narrowing
down the range of possibilities it's
fine just good I just finish this
because you also alluded to a
policymakers and of course you know they
want to have certain answers but very
often they are not prepared to accept
there is a bandwidth and you can advise
them but only within a certain
specialist they want a point and they
don't know where the point is on a curve
here's the bandwidth that they want the
point over there if there's an end with
they say no that's not a point so let's
get a point so if we if we take the
stand point that evidence from
scientific sources varies and but it
tends to come with a bandwidth why is it
that people have not learned that why do
people expect it to give you precise
answers is it because we're all
subjected to the sort of I don't know
the media view that I don't know smoking
will give you lung cancer or eating too
much broccoli is somehow bad fee or
whatever it is you know everything is
reduced to this cause an effect status
is that I'm actually think that if we
just think about the basic truth in
science and that is using some knowledge
we can predict what's going to happen
but isn't just in science I mean almost
everyone would agree that if I were to
pour this on your pants they would get
with and you would not necessarily be
very happy so that is something or if I
close my eyes and walk too in that
direction at some point I'm gonna fall
off the stage and brave you break my leg
so everyone is very aware of this the
people who believe in fake news if you
said to them you know here's a glass of
water and here's a glass of arsenic
choose which one you want to drink you
know then no one will touch the arsenic
so they're really so there are certain
things which and I think we want to do
that in general with everything I think
the difficulty with prediction is it
works pretty well short term like
weather but it really breaks down long
term
and you know for example if we look at
the pretty the biggest discovery in the
last 15 years was the smartphone you
know Steve Jobs his design of that
particular phone I don't think anyone
predicted it and has had a bigger effect
in a few really wants to be
controversial you could say that it had
a bigger effect in society then you know
all the Nobel prizes put together just
because it's given everybody
communication and computer brain power
in their hands it works in any language
there's no keyboard etc etc so I think
that uncertainty you know is something
which it's it's difficult to know why
people are so concerned about certainty
and I you know I think that I personally
enjoy uncertainty more than certainty I
think also you know if we think about
what other smart people have told us
they in the area of meditation for them
you only live in the prison now one of
the big criticisms of Donald Trump today
was that he's only living in the prison
so you know it's interesting how these
things go together than we were saying
that worrying about the future comes
from not living in the present but I
think ultimately you know every second
we were alive is worth so much wonder
but instead of worrying about what's
gonna happen tomorrow is very uncertain
we may not be here who knows and you
know you can worry about it if you're
making the policy but you probably
shouldn't worry about it because you
could easily be wrong I have this image
sometimes of somebody who was very
pessimistic all his life and you know
he's on his deathbed and sudden he looks
back if there's gee nothing bad ever
happened to me he's gonna think what a
waste I could have done all these
interesting things and I was very
pessimistic I avoided them I think
ultimately we don't know but basically
life is fairly coherent by and large the
world gets through three difficult times
I think we have to always realize that
everything is super amplified by media
and it doesn't matter whether it's
printing books 500 years ago or in a fly
sheets or propaganda or whatever and you
know things are basically like this but
basically things sort of continue
pretty long otherwise they wouldn't be
an earth if there wasn't continuity we
wouldn't have ever have evolved life if
every single day the laws of physics
changed we would have real uncertainty
I would like to come back to this
cause-effect example that you brought in
here with with the glass not gonna do
even if you ask me no I'm not going to
test your willingness to do it but I
think you know evolution has equipped us
for seeing and anticipating cause-effect
relationships that were important for
our survival and this is an evolutionary
instinct that we have had bestowed upon
us but now we live in a world that has
become much more complex than surviving
in a jungle or surviving hero until your
next meal and we are not equipped to see
the unintended consequences of our
action and that's a big problem
especially in a society where we see all
the interconnections if you think of
climate change is one example where you
have to take into account atmospheric
circulation energy use regulation
everything it's such a complex web of
inter linkages where you have also newly
emergent properties is that and we are
not equipped for that but science
provides us ways of looking a bit
further ahead of seeing at least some of
these interconnections and this is
something that we have to get across
much better to society and to say it
comes with uncertainties of course but
this is part but you get something in
return you can look a little bit further
ahead you can prepare for certain things
even if you know it's still fraught with
uncertainties hmm indeed I do
I'd like to just quickly discuss the I
connect ssin between belief and truth in
science I typed in scientifically true
to Google and the two top things that
came up were is interstellar the film
scientifically true
and is the Bible scientifically true and
that seemed the first okay the second
seemed to be a prime example of trying
to apply the scientific method to
conditions where you should not be
applying the scientific method but
people so is it fair to say that people
try in their whatever understanding of
the scientific method they have to apply
it to everything to kind of shore up
their own belief system but a lot of it
is kind of inappropriate application of
the method what do you think well I
think the scientific method is a very
good brand you know it has very good
reputations it's created wonders and so
people want to have it on their their
own beliefs and ways of life they want
the brand that this is certified by the
scientific method but it's not so easy
the scientific method is a very specific
thing that has to do with domains of
knowledge or you can do repeated
experiments and quantify and control and
even within science what we usually call
science that doesn't apply to all
branches other for some branches have
contingent facts and need modifications
of the scientist historians of science
said there is not one scientific method
there are many different kinds of
scientific methods yes indeed yes but
you know one interesting example because
you mentioned the Bible had it not been
for German philologists it's the turn of
the 19th century starting to look
critically with scientific methods to
the Bible you know we would still be
there where many people are with the
Quran today you know it has been it's
it's it's a book that has been written
according to the words of God and what
this critical analysis of the Bible
brought was a lot of evidence if you
want you know when was it written most
likely by home what was superseding it
so it was sort of dismantling a
religious truth and turning it into a
historical call its cultural artifacts
or whatever you want to call it and I
think this is a good example of the
scientific method that was brought on to
something that was close before us don't
touch it because it's not amenable to
scientific ways of inquiry okay
thank you I would like to I would like
to open up for questions
do we have any questions or comments
from the audience please be thinking yes
in the front please Kelly so you have
all explained very well
why we have to accept uncertainty we
have to live with it and we may even
have to embrace it
but when we select our leaders in
business in politics and so forth we
want them to be forceful them we want
them to have a clear view and we
certainly do not want uncertainty in
leadership I think in a way we would be
much better off if we could have leaders
to have wisdom rather than fanatism but
how do we get there so just a deal but I
think that if we were to apply the
methods for selecting leaders to other
walks of life so we would choose our
best scientists by how many people voted
for them if the head of a big company
was somebody randomly chosen or who had
a big network I think we wouldn't really
succeed very well and I think in some
ways it's interesting how
politics and leadership and I think you
know there's discussions of democracy
versus non democracy but I think that
you know do we actually have a to
democracy anywhere in the world I don't
know when the power of lobbyists is as
powerful it is in the USA and you can
buy politicians maybe they should just
be bought outright maybe Google should
come to the you know the Prime Minister
of Britain and say look you're going to
get 10 million dollars when you leave
you're going to do what I say and that's
it make it out right but I think there
is hope and this actually comes the very
first session this morning we heard some
clips of people being asked and the last
person was saying that he hoped that
errors say of artificial intelligence
could actually help inform government
and one thing I remember I was here two
years ago when the actual dialogue was
about artificial intelligence and
somebody from IBM spoke about the Watson
that could actually play chess for any
really well and now there are many
better computers on that well I had a
sort of feeling wouldn't it be wonderful
if every president of the USA or every
politician had a it was mandated to go
and ask the computer what I should do
you know do I invite invade Iraq and the
computer would say yes or no he wouldn't
have to listen to the computer that
decision will be recorded I just somehow
feel that they are gonna be in the
future much much better ways in some
ways you know if we look at maybe the
best system in the world right now is
United States it was when it was written
over 200 years ago
there are very few scientific theories
that still hold after 200 years I think
our whole way of doing things needs a
lot of improvement and we need to do
that hello how about to choose leaders
of course it's an older topic it starts
with Plato who wanted the philosophers
to be the philosopher king and also in
the 18th century condor se was thinking
about how he could apply mathematics
today we would say let's have an
algorithm to choose the best system and
to determine what the population wants
and you run it mathematically
and hmm I think we are cautious that we
do not want to have our leader chosen by
an algorithm and I think we are right in
doing that but we could do much better
in setting up the criteria what is it we
expect from our leaders and just to give
you one one example this was a political
scientist working at Columbia University
by the name of Garland's and he had
looked at democracies that died
especially in Latin America and one of
his findings was they had leaders who
did not condone violence and who did
nothing to protect minorities of any
kind and these were the worst predictive
predictors for a very bad outcome so I
think we can set up some criteria that
we want to hold our leaders accountable
to and these would be two very important
ones we seem to be arguing that the
scientific method can be very widely
applied to every sphere of life hi I
cease application scientific methods
have been applied with great success to
ticking out the best baseball players
for the money the best basketball
players for the money and and I think
also now in corporate recruiting and
certainly when we choose students we
evaluate based on a lot of information
that we require to be supplied I think
it's quite scandalous that when we elect
political leaders we ask so little of
them to just describe themselves in
quantitative ways that to supply their
tax returns to maybe take some exams to
get some sense of what they really are
capable of or consists of so I know that
would be a revolution but I
it would not be a bad idea to to be more
rigorous in choosing presidents for
instance it makes perfect sense to the
standards of the National Basketball
Association it makes perfect sense but
I'm still stuck on this I'm courting
this dichotomy this this idea that we we
know this we we we know this and yet
people are very willing to grab a piece
of evidence and use it as the whole
basis for making a decision and kind of
put their belief in it and go with it
why is there why why do people do that I
think that probably human beings have
been hardwired for tribalism and for me
competing teams you know somebody who
supports one basketball team this is
another team they'll kill each other for
that and it's something which is totally
interchangeable there's nothing a priori
better about say the Red Sox versus
something else and I'm not a sports fan
but perfectly logical sensible people
take sports very seriously and I think
you know that's probably good for them
but that same energy is then put into
religions it's put into politics and I
think in all cases it probably has about
the same level of scientific basis it's
worrying but I think this it's it's a
it's a human condition introducing about
I would slightly disagree I think if you
look back at evolution it is a mixture
between competition and cooperation and
we are now discovering you know the
amount of cooperation which actually
happens among bacteria among various
life-forms etc that was necessary while
you have competition at at the same time
and once this gets out of balance in our
societies and we are seeing now it does
get out of balance because we have lots
of competition and we have less and less
cooperation because we have a
fragmentation and this fragmentation is
reinforced through social media because
then people can close themselves off in
mind
and in in body in terms of their bubble
and they don't even want to hear or they
ignore that there's anything outside of
it and this goes back to partly the
leaders that are I would hold them
accountable you know if you let a
society fragment in so many ways there
is something deeply wrong with allowing
this to happen
hmm we have another question here please
oh if you could use the microphone thank
you
hi and thank you for a great discussion
and I want to go back to where you
started on the concept of patience
because for me it's a lot about what
you're talking about is a time frame
where you expect a change in the near
time future so how do we expand our time
frame to like how do we get more
patience in the society it's a good
question well patience gets forced upon
us I'm not using but hagit but how do
those in society who are desperate for
an answer now yeah learn to wait and
bide their time leaders and the general
public who need to be behind those
leaders who wants to go for it take a
vow you know I think I mean in some of
these patients I think is something
which is probably always a good idea
things are never as bad as they seem
they're pretty never as good as they
seem we tend to amplify things both
positively and negatively one thing that
is interesting is that by all
statistical accounts the world has never
been in better shape than it is now even
with the problems of global warming ie
literacy is super high childbirth is
really low poverty is getting lower and
lower and lower there are graphs that
show how things have changed over the
last 200 years and everything looks
amazing violence is done you know people
killed in military action is way down
than what it used to be and people all
believe the
and that's something which we need we
need to think about I think and if we
believe things are the conscious of the
fact that is a very bad idea because the
facts are true and I think that you know
if you looked at a global view of the
world I mean one really really important
change in the last twenty years is that
what used to be the preserve of the West
has now become adopted by almost the
entire globe and this basically means
that there's more competition and more
competition is a really good idea
because you could actually argue that's
you know what's maybe bad for the
Americans is really good for the Chinese
and if you think about yourself as a
citizen of the world that's fine I think
if if a cut you know if you want to
assume if you want to do really stupid
things let's imagine you refuse to
vaccinate your children at some point
you become extinct it's very hard lesson
and if you aren't prepared to worry
about you know good renewable energy at
some point your companies will be buying
only Chinese things and you're going to
run out of money so it seems to me that
this is a good buffer the fact that the
world is not only much better off in
terms of these indicators but also much
more globally United I think it's an
enormously positive force for the future
I would agree with you that the world is
better off in many ways but at the same
time our standards our expectations our
values have also evolved and we are now
demanding inclusiveness we are we think
it's self-evident that people with
disabilities you know our part of
society that we have to do everything
you know to make them feel part of the
society and so on so many things remain
that are ugly in terms of and
underdeveloped in terms of our values
but nevertheless there is an evolution
of our values and of our standards of
morality as well therefore I think in in
science I agree you know patience means
to be persistent and
this is important but in society I think
we have a right to be impatient because
we have this wonderful means we have all
the science we have the technology we
have models of complexity simulations
you know that let us look ahead etc and
we have a right to implement the
insights that we gained from so be
impatient you have the right you should
be realistic about what you're up
against
I agree with that but these kinds of
questions go way back to philosophers
like Seneca and Plato who talked about
the self-control and if people want to
learn about patience I just urge them to
reflect on their own life and their
experiences I know in my life some of
the things I most regret was when I lost
patience got angry did something
impulsive and so that that's a way of
learning patience and wisdom but that
doesn't mean complacency I mean you
stand that you but but you have to be
realistic and and that's necessary in
order to be persistent if you get too
easily discouraged because you were too
optimistic then you give up you don't so
that that's not a virtue it's so
patience doesn't mean complacency
patience means setting goals that are
ambitious but being realistic about it's
not gonna be easy and it's gonna take
time thank you okay I'm calm coming to
it thank you very much indeed thank you
much Michael just just Michael raise the
question the the the issue of
vaccination and for many scientists
that's sort of the poster child case of
people making decisions based on little
evidence wrongly and really not
understanding and I think a lot of
scientists at a loss to understand why
and earth all these educated people are
rejecting something it is so obviously a
good idea you know if you want another
exam
I remember finding really shocking I in
the biophysicist and I visited the
European election Balaji lab in actually
at that time in in Cambridge rather than
in Heidelberg and basically in the
canteen and this was probably 20 years
ago they said no German no GMO food is
served here and I was shocked so this is
an issue where I think the Americans are
way ahead of the Europeans there is no
evidence everyone seems to agree with
that
and yet we believe very strongly about
how bad this is now you know maybe there
is evidence I'm not trying to say there
isn't but you know it's again certain
things we believe in you know today at
lunch it said it's in our lunch there
was no lactose it was lactose on the
food and at some level this level of
sensitivity you know variety is a really
good idea and if you if you're very
lactose intolerant maybe you should you
know be very very careful but it seems
to we can't worry about that always if
you listen to people mmm these educated
people they give you other reasons I
mean if you dig a bit deeper and it's
really the interest of the individual
against the interest of the population
because we know unless a certain
percentage of the population is
vaccinated you are not protected and
it's the hmm if you want the egotism of
the parents of a child who say you know
my child is more important what do I
care about the rest of society so it's
not so much disputing what science says
but saying you know I have my interest
to protect my child against you know all
kinds of imagined risks that are
associated with vaccinations and also
with GM's always I was in Switzerland at
the time when there was the referendum
for or against GM or now it turned out
that in the the same country in the
german-speaking part people were much
more risk-averse than in the
french-speaking part so you say well
this culture yeah
the friend
more risk-loving than the
german-speaking but then it turned out
that the reasons behind it below it
we're in the german-speaking part of
switzerland you have an agriculture a
monoculture you have vast and people
were afraid that Monsanto would take
over you know the the seeds would have
to be bought every year cetera in the
french-speaking but you have mountains
you have very little agriculture so
people did not care yeah so I'm just
saying very often there are other
interests below it
I'm not saying you know this is better
it's worse but it's not so much the
science is an easy target it becomes
easy to attack and we would make a
mistake in interpreting everything is
anti science without looking deeper into
it thank you thank you please question
my question would be to the panel about
your thoughts on the importance of
education as we heard earlier today
there is some threat to our universities
and our educators and as an educator I'm
really concerned what I hear and
particularly will you be mentioning
things like uncertainty and as an
educator how do we as educator then take
that forward to our students please
Michael Kaiser
I think directly dealing with education
it seems to me that one area of Science
and Mathematics and has been really
neglected at school education is
statistics and uncertainty is a very
infancy part of statistics and it seems
to me that you know even six or old
children should be given dice and you
know mate make distributions and
understand what a mean is and a standard
deviation get some feeling or what
statistic there's and I think that this
is something I don't even know the
history of why for example we teach
people how to add fractions which is
number theory but we totally ignore
sadistic in school and it's a lot of
people think statistics is very
difficult but basically it's very easy
to do experimental statistics just have
children throw a coin and record the
throws and you can analyze that change
so I think that would be my number one
recommendation for schools well I think
education is all important and I'm very
pleased that people have started to
quantify that in a way that that can be
transmitted as objective data
this was a very recent study from out of
Harvard and elsewhere that compared
identified talented children in the
early stages of their education with
different kinds of backgrounds different
income levels different genders and so
forth and then their eventual
contribution to the economy as were
especially to innovation as quantified
by the number of patents they got and so
forth and there was a tremendous
correlation between
or anti correlation between the income
level and these other factors gender and
and the eventual outcome so talent you
could identify talent but if you don't
nurture it it's a great loss to society
any innovation is ultimately what drives
economic growth in the long run economic
advancement for everybody there's
nothing more important and we can put
our finger on what it'll take to improve
that and I think the single most
important thing is to make sure that
everybody gets a good a good chance at
education let me just we have another
question but let me just first do you
think that education science education
teaches the scientific method well I
mean do people come out of school
general people come out of school
knowing what the scientific method is or
do they think that the science is all
about certainties
hold on no III think there's a big
mistake that is being done in the way
how we present science we present it
very often with the end results and we
say look you know this is the outcome
believe it or not but it's the authority
of science that tells you this is the
outcome and we do far too little to take
people through the process what does it
actually mean to do research and there's
this wonderful way of how far surgical
spoke about de science and Nightside and
de science for him was you know the
finished product you can bask in the
glory of having achieved something but
then there's nice science you are
frustrated your experiment does not work
you have to start again and it's one
side two sides of the same matter and to
explain to people what it actually means
to do research how to think about an
experiment how to set it up what you do
if it does not work etc and you can do
it with very simple ways and build it
into the curriculum and I think this
would be the way forward and of course
it means also statistics people are not
well equipped to think in terms of
probabilities but if you explain to them
in natural frequency they get the point
so there are ways of overcoming it and
mmm so I think this is really the way
how to go I can suite Sweden in the
winter time is therefore a very good
representation of science long long
nights and very short days what occurs
to me here at time is that the
scientific method isn't something you
put in a box and only apply to physics
or only apply to things we call science
it's it's a way of thinking that is kind
of coterminous with just rational
thought and people can learn the
scientific method from things that you
don't necessarily think of as science
from solving puzzles they can learn
static person in our it occurred to me
during this long discussion of
statistics
for instance and uncertainty that people
gamble people analyze sports teams and
their averages and in a very very very
sophisticated ways and they're doing
statistics they're doing science without
realizing that it's science and I think
so I think there are many opportunities
to teach people how to think
scientifically how to think rationally
besides teaching them physics or
chemistry and one last thought on this
which is that people are sometimes
saying oh it's too difficult for me
calculus is too difficult for me you
know that they should realize that all
of that any of any particular branch of
science that I know of is simpler and
easier to learn than a language and
almost everyone learns a language and so
you shouldn't people shouldn't be
intimidated they should know that it's
humans who did it
Fineman used to say what one fool can
invent another / another fool can
understand
[Laughter]
let me just go back there is not the one
scientific method there are different
scientific approaches and there was a
molecular biologist well-known - Michael
Waddington the discovery of epigenetics
way back in the in the in the forties
and he wrote a book in the 1940s at a
dark time in Europe he was afraid that
Nazi Germany would overrun England at
that time or that the English government
would give in just as the French
government had given in and in this
moment he wrote a book called the
scientific attitude and it's only about
applying the scientific attitude to the
problems of his time and it's a it's a
great book and I think this is probably
the message that we should take from
this discussion the scientific attitude
scientific way of looking at the world
and applying it wherever we think it is
necessary thank you
but would
be a perfect end point but there's been
a very patient person is a microphone
this and we should take that last
question I have a question for actually
professor Helga so you've said that when
it comes to research if you know what
you're looking for not actually doing
any research so I mean as far as I'm a
physics student so as far as physics is
concerned
isn't that statement more related to
experimental physics than theoretical
physics because I asked pastor Frank
pointed out Einstein knew what he would
expect because of his theory of gravity
and he said okay light would Bend this
certain amount and I think that actually
found that it actually been there almost
the same exact amount so theoretical
physics is a form of research so what
would you have to say about that I'm
sorry I did not understand everyone's
the question - professor Otto professor
Haley
rezidentura yeah well I I try to explain
what serendipity is and third dippity
means you're discovering whatever you do
in research a new phenomenon you are
discovering a cause effect relation you
are discovering a new substance that
nobody has discovered before and you do
it by chance it happens by chance it's
one side but then you have to realize
its significance because very often
these things pop up and you think well
it's noise it's not important etc and
there are famous examples for instance
in high-temperature superconductivity
there was a team that found exactly what
the people who got the Nobel Prize for
later because they knew the significance
of what they found so let's thank you
very much very much thank you for your
question okay
sadly we are over time and as you know
I'm not allowed to go over time so we
have just no I'd like to thank all three
of my wonderful panelists and you all
for being here thanks very much indeed
[Applause]